fachleute sind besorgt denn in
deutschland breiten sich riesige tropen
zecken aus bereits sieben exemplare
wurden bei uns entdeckt die experten und
expertinnen fürchten dass die blutsauger
jetzt auch bei uns heimisch werden
könnten denn auch der mensch ist ein
potenzieller wird und ein aufgespürt das
exemplar trug ein gefährliches bakterium
ähnlich wo die parasiten bereits
auftauchen welche schäden sie
hinterlassen
und womit wir im zusammenhang der
klimaerwärmung noch so alles zu rechnen
haben das alles und noch viel mehr
jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen jetzt kommen die
veränderung klimawandel und die
hitzewellen der letzten jahre fordern
ihren tribut die natur verändert sich
bei und siedeln jetzt auf materie die
eigentlich woanders heimisch sind bisher
sind es nur sieben exemplare der gattung
hat die 2018 in deutschland gefunden
wurden
doch fachleute sind sich einig die
gefahr besteht dass sich die parasiten
auch hier bei uns etablieren könnten
quasi fest weißen dazu ute mackenstedt
von der universität hohenheim
diese zeiten könnten in deutschland
einzug halten
wir werden sie in diesem jahr verstärkt
im auge behalten und bereiten uns darauf
vor ihr in den nächsten monaten
womöglich noch öfters zu begegnen
aufgetaucht waren die ziemlich großen
zecken in osnabrück im raum hannover und
in der wetterau auch wahrscheinlich
wurden sie über vögel eingeschleppt
konkret wurden drei von ihnen an einem
einzigen fährt eine an einem schaf und
drei weitere an drei einzelnen pferden
entdeckt auch wenn die zahl sieben erst
einmal nicht nach wie klingt bereitet
die entdeckung den forschungsteams
sorgen denn ein exemplar trug ein
gefährliches bakterium in sich konkret
handelt es sich um regt sie an die ein
bekannter erreger des ecken fleckfieber
sven er auf den menschen übergehen kann
dazu fieber und veränderungen führen
2002 wurde die erste infektion an einem
menschen dokumentiert der patient konnte
erfolgreich behandelt werden die
blutsauger können prinzipiell auch das
krim kongo hämorrhagisches fieber und
das arabische moralische fieber
übertragen
die bisher in deutschland nicht
aufgetreten sind diese beiden erreger
wurden allerdings in den hier gefunden
zecken auch nicht die
identifiziert zudem gelten sie auch als
überträger tropische erkrankung von
nutztieren ja und ursprünglich kommen
die zecken in den trockengebieten von
afrika asien und südeuropa vor in mittel
und nordeuropa dagegen bislang nicht
charakteristisch für die parasiten sind
ihre auffällige streiften beine im
vergleich zu den zeckenarten die wir aus
deutschland kennt sind sie deutlich
größer ja die zecken saugen vor allem an
großen tieren blut dabei können sie sich
aktiv auf ihren wirt zu bewegen dafür
können sie eine strecke von bis zu 100
metern zurücklegen und auch menschen
dienen als wirte die laufen und nymphen
der tiere besiedeln vor allem kleinen
säugetiere und vögel bisher gab es von
dieser tropischen sec naht der gattung
über nur zwei einzelfunde in deutschland
zwar in den jahren 2015 und 2017 das
jetzt vermehrt auftauchen ist den
experten und expertinnen zufolge kein
wunder und auf den heißen und trockenen
sommer zurückzuführen
und diese parasiten werden in den
kommenden jahren sicher nicht die
einzigen bleiben die sich auch bei uns
heimisch fühlen dazu mackenstedt wegen
der klimaerwärmung ist bei uns
grundsätzlich mit immer mehr wärme
liebenden zecken zu rechnen
dxo destino pilatus aus dem
mittelmeerraum beispielsweise hat sich
inzwischen bis dänemark ausgebreitet
fraglich ist jetzt nur noch ob sich die
art bereits in deutschland etabliert hat
oder ob es sich nur um einzelne
eingeschleppte exemplare handelt das
will das forschungsteam aus hohenheim
jetzt genauer untersuchen
da man den zeitraum kennt den die
parasiten für ihre entwicklung brauchen
könne man abschätzen ob sie sich in
deutschland etablieren könnten wenn es
zunehmend heißer und trockener wird dazu
mackenstedt bei einer art der
ursprünglich in afrika beheimateten
braunen hunde cnpc fahr los sei ruinös
sind exemplare an hunden gefunden worden
die ihren hof nie verlassen hat damit
konnten sie kein unbeabsichtigtes
urlaubsmitbringsel seien ein hinweis
darauf dass sich die art hier
möglicherweise bereits entwickeln kann
wenn er kein video verpassen wollt auch
extra videos und livestreams nicht dann
werdet mitglieder auf dem kanal und
nimmt noch ein paar privilegien mit
außerdem unterstützte und mit einem
kleinen betrag einfach auf mitglied
werden hier unter dem video klicken
allen die jetzt geklickt haben und auch
schon bisher ein riesen dankeschön
das macht uns etwas unabhängiger von den
schwankenden werbeeinnahmen und wenn er
immer garantiert über aktuelle videos
informiert werden wollt dann endet mich
also klicks um bei whatsapp darum geht
ihr die etwas unzuverlässige abo box
hier auf youtube und ihren verpasst kein
video einfach hier draufklicken und am
besten auch meine schwester karla kick
zum social media abonnieren dafür hier
klicken aber nicht die genau die glocke
vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür
auch draufklicken das große insekten
sterben bis dahin bleibt dran